my real name is Brad it was born with it  Brad Pitt transforms back into his 90s  heartthrob self by switching up one  thing his Brad Aging in Reverse we think  so after the oscar-winning actor stepped  out clean shaven and looking decades  younger at the LACMA art and film gala  honoring mark Bradford and George Lucas  on Saturday the 53 year old superstar  brought back his signature spiky hair  and showed off his charming grin to  mingle with guests there's no word if  the fresh-faced look is for a role but  Brad is currently filming his new movie  ad astra a source tells ET the actor has  been keeping a low profile on set quote  when he's not on set filming he hangs  out in his trailer he's never late and  he always arrives to set ready to work  it's really strong entertaining  entertaining story  [Music]  you